[Música]
[Aplausos]
bush você wachivanga chegou à porta do
inferno a confessa com deus eu estou eu
estou tenho uma mão estendida é quem
parece interferir caem sul
e eu que sou e não outro trailer vida
escrita mas eu nunca aprendi i tele
tem um pet caos de outro pé na cova
estou pronto para a prova
quem não tem nada não tem nada a perder
quem não sabe nova às vezes vidas torna
zelo e minha esposa de poesia e prosa
mesmo sem peta os uma rosa é uma rosa
até a minha poderosa você apontar um
dedo de deus e choveram sempre novos
para apontar erros meus jacques um lugar
no sol
jacques 1 no ranking dos céus
hoje estou à porta do inferno a conversa
com deus mas rosé cama deus aporte do
inferno a confessa é com deus eu estou
eu estou tenho uma mão estendida e perde
é quem para perder e ser quem sou o que
sou e no outro tânia vida escrita mas eu
nunca aprendi a ler
layer continuamos aqui sabemos ler o
manual chegou hoje nós aqui sabem
escrever uma nova chuva quem ex-cabo ler
e escrever
quem aqui andou na escola
basicamente o número de mãos a todas
estas perguntas foi igual a maior parte
nós aprendeu a ler e escrever na escola
a questão que eu queria colocar aqui e
não é encontrado alguma resposta para
esta questão mas às vezes é essa o bom
questionar não é colocando assim um pano
tentar perceber o que realmente passa no
presente questão será que nós sabemos o
que é
lê e o que é escrever
será que a escola ensina meses
são duas questões não é tão longe mas
comentar já estão a passar à frente pra
vocês
a letra a letra r
ah e é dar o banho
temos a ideia e o conceito ao juntar
duas letras a a fazer agora aqui mais
uma letra a letra a é
e ah tá
há outro conceito a ler
ae
vocês vêem o ar bem o ar como é que nós
vemos o ar o que eu canto a ordem das
letras roma
já para muita gente é deus deus pra
muita gente não se vê assim como o ar
essa é uma forma de leitura e escrita
chega é que nós utilizamos símbolos e
letras que aprendemos na escola
construímos realidades
construímos idéias conceitos e estas
ideias e com 7 trazendo soluções e
soluções que são urgentes
sei que tenho ver este em casa talvez
não vai perceber mas nós tivemos aqui
antes de entrar em palco algo que é
mesmo urgente é e atuar sobre e quando
uma situação urgente de atuar
eu acho que a coisa que você pode fazer
mesmo mudar essa situação é mudar a
realidade ler e escrever
o nosso ambiente e inventar agora vamos
apresentar aqui alguém ou alguma coisa
a letra p letra a e b ea letra p letra o
meio papo conhece o papo
reconheço a poeta manual
vocês que não conhece o papo conseguem
descrever o papo não essa importância de
saber ler e saber escrever quando nós
também vamos ler nem escrever
nós não conseguimos ver não vemos e
importância nós criamos nosso próprio
vocabulário é estender nosso vocabulário
porque estamos a pressão e mais
conhecimento das mais consciência do
nosso ambiente e tendo mais consciência
sobre nossos ambientes
conseguimos posicionar os neo da melhor
forma
através de nosso olhar
mas calma papo papo de ser o que é uma
pessoa papo disse que papo conversa
este é o papo
alguém imaginou hoje a cedente como afro
papo
este é o papo papo aí ó paí ó papo papo
é foi
um dos responsáveis eu aprender a ler e
de aprender a escrever escrever o meu
primeiro livro da primária primeira
classe foi ele compreender que o pp ea
pá feio ou pá ou ajudar símbolos porque
isso que são letras símbolos e o que
mais me foi china é que são símbolos que
nós nem questionamos porque com a ua
porque com a ua adensado não quem sabe
até manual que é o quê com a ael a já
encontramos assim não é isso mesmo então
isto é quase um capitão um salto de fé
nós acreditamos que o à e aquela letra
que nós devemos usar contando escrever a
área a eurocopa-2012 ensinaram de alguma
forma fé pé é base
nós queremos construir alguma coisa nós
queremos escrever de fato alguma coisa
se nós queremos ler o que está à nossa
volta
a fé é um papel importante se mano
às vezes é preciso mesmo só acreditar
plenárias símbolos ou ximos nós
construímos últimos que nós criamos
adotamos todos parte da nossa realidade
parte nosso sistema de crenças
o papo papo
o primeiro livro mãe estudar em portugal
a primeira classe uma escola em que eu
era o único preto
o único preto primeiro dia de aulas
eu cheguei com minha mãe
o fórum se com o sítio um dos pais é que
eles terão que acompanhar as crianças
também foram deixados necessita entrada
da escola eo toca a entrar os pais
despediram se de nós entramos
nós entramos na escola a caminho da sala
de aula
chegamos à sala de aula entrou 13 em
eu ia entrar então a minha professora
não é piada
dona branca não é piada
havia uma questão que tínhamos
contratado do jes tica
então eu tive que acordar e ficar gorda
que chamassem minha mãe que tinha
acabado de deixar e que àquela hora já
estava a caminho do emprego novo
telemóvel claro aquela altura
sou muito velho e não é que a minha mãe
voltasse pra escola demorou
minha mãe chegou estava lá num átrio
mezatrio descer na minha mãe seu filho
não pode ser da primeira classe mas como
assim não porque eu não tenho dado não
foi dado com já viu o tamanho de seu
filho
amém esse episódio não me incomodou nada
nada a minha mãe ea minha mãe pra
história
arraste eu senti uma noção de frente as
coisas talvez por ser muito ingênuo
talvez ser preto pra mim nunca foi razão
no centro mal comigo próprio nunca
isso pra mim é um privilégio porque há
pessoas que não tá é pra mim é mesmo uma
sorte de não sentir falta de autoestima
por exemplo por ser desta cor e teve
várias razões país
como sabemos há várias razões
papo encontrar este livro capa do livro
aliás esta imagem estamos a ver
anteriormente encontrei também esta
mensagem eu vou ler porque aí não só
esse tão claro que diz no livro do papo
que acho que era o primeiro havia uma
história em que eu e meu irmão é trekker
a irmã fazia uma viagem com
boy eo apreciar as nuvens e imaginado
formavam castelos e animais era
ilustrado por uma imagem dos dois
a ge melo do combóio os nuvens em pano
de fundo é duráveis e imagem fazia
viajar num espaço de tranquilidade
tenho 34 anos e ainda hoje me vem à
cabeça muitas vezes e faz-nos sentir tão
tranquila e alegre como no morro chais o
eder pereira da buraca na amadora por
causa da minha vizinha mora ali perto
isto acrescentou álcool
a minha visão a minha leitura do que era
o livro papo o office uma dimensão com o
qual eu me identifico a leitura das
nuvens
a leitura do vento a leitura do ar
a leitura das árvores a leitura das
águas
essa leitura parte do subsídio e de um
sítio que é extremamente preto chama que
eu vou falar
este foi sem um dos meus ensaios preço
da apresentação
não vou explicar o que está aqui aumento
mas vou explicar o que foi a seguir esta
imagem
o anterior era um bom ensaio esta imagem
foi através de um amigo meu chamado
pedro fernandes um artista ilustrador
pedro fernandes pf trabalha comigo eu
mostrei o meu ensaio e diz
esta ideia é este esta ideia vem de um
filme confiar caminho de luanda há dois
dias atrás no avião se chama a música do
silêncio
o andrea bocelli sobrevida deus do
cantor
eu queria retratar era mesmo o andrea
bocelli e o que representou através
desse filme quando eu ouvi um pode ver
num ensaio pra mim aquela parte lá de
cima por exemplo andrea bocelli andrea
bocelli e não sei se toda a gente
conhece o setor de obra e que ficou
completamente em visual a partir dos 12
anos de idade eu já nasceu com alguns
distúrbios visuais mas depois
gradualmente foi pirando teve um
acidente se dizem que foi no futebol ou
bola na cabeça e ficou completamente
cego às escuras
então eu dizia um terceiro olho na
televisão de alguém que ficou seco
responder por aqui como o design tem
mais dois olhos então os dois olhos
abertos
quando mostrei minha visão partilhada
minha leitura o meu amigo pedro
fernandes
eu desenho apenas um olho e duas folhas
não fazem lembrar completamente alguém
que é cego então acrescentou a minha
visão isso quer dizer que a configuração
é nossa visão daquilo que é nossa
realidade também é feita através da
compressão também é feita através
daquilo que tal vosso lado daquela ao
vosso lado
isso é extremamente importante criar
construir realidades em conjunto o carro
no cerne da questão e depois deixar de
passar
andrea bocelli no final do filme
esta frase é basicamente rotos a ideia
de que nada é o caso da coisa unidade
não existe e que causou lhe dado uma
tentativa de pessoas baixas e horgan
antes de deturpar a verdade ao favor das
leis da razão
uma frase de andrea bocelli cego ao
tempo não vê mas que tem uma grande
leitura
ok vamos deixar agora vou fazer nenhum
momento isto tive um sonho e o chute pra
mim torná-los é vez seja painéis em que
eu tomar atenção e também faz algumas
leituras que aplicam o dia a dia e na
vida real quando estou acordado este
sonho alguém foi à janela e disse romero
do fundo a que deve fazer o que fazer
como assim
esse é o seu lugar
o lugar não é à toa o acordar e quando
acordou e resolvi fazer isto
[Música]
estuda se tratar por que não
saiba
[Música]
nabuco 2002 hans resolvi sair
e cada vez mais comum e um lápis em da
frente junto como inexistente
[Música]
o acordo vezes alves votantes após briga
alma nómada
é cada pessoal do bar
[Música]
eu estou bebendo
ae
[Música]
caí na bahia local
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ele é total
o teclado da luta justificou
ae
abr
o trono não tinha o tempo dá o que fugir
o tempo passa a campanha todos contra o
velho
ele descansou vida cada vez mais um
pouco mais o domínio da energia é que dá
uns amiga a pedra mais me chama a 60 no
palco eu deixo de ler cada treino
[Música]
não sou o dono do meu
[Aplausos]
[Música]
a minha cara bom
ae
[Música]
to
mas nós estamos a pensar e viver é
preciso parar de fumar assim área e
venceu como ela é e não como estamos a
pensar na importância pensava
o homem é louco existe em todo o
espectro do luxo de que aquilo que é
perfeita
vejo que não existe da curia acredita em
mim
o teste foi tomar café em cada produto
ou mesmo tópico plate que o foco se
volta à vida como ela é e não como
estamos a pensar e voltamos a pensar e
voltamos a pensar
voltamos a pensar um pouquinho só pensar
e voltamos a pensar e voltamos a pensar
encontramos e pensar
qualquer um